my flavors were one of my babies from
down the corner baby
this is big he's a beautiful boy
this might be big happy big he's a good
guy he came Paris
my flavor will with the cats on the
corner we I'm gonna do see you later to
be a buddy big here at chick
[ __ ] filet J's are going
[ __ ] crazy we're in Hollywood today
they're gonna kiss each other and [ __ ]
here look at this guy's got the [ __ ]
sign for free you got all my guys here
you got the blonde with the big tits
it's happening here at chick
[ __ ] Soleil you follow me and
nobody's here look at nobody's pissed
off nobody knows nothing this is Holly
with all the drama and all that that's
at that time dick get some [ __ ] [ __ ]
out here with [ __ ] sticks and chains
and beat these [ __ ] Christians
to death stay black Burbank Boulevard
and evergreen I'm at the [ __ ]
headquarters here a tenth planet
Eddie Bravo's [ __ ] jointly let's see
what savages are in here tonight
what the [ __ ] at his teaching
in the back there they are [ __ ] Ronda
Rousey you see in the back back there
that's how they [ __ ] do it right
there
those [ __ ] Johnny karate that he
is they know I'm pea stay black any
problems joint for me it's just great to
come up this I can't fit a man for you
as I watch the counter so this was for
me I got mad flavor and death over here
my buddy's bike he's [ __ ] pedaling
like a savage like is like a Puerto
Rican rickshaw I'm on right now mad
flavor damaging at the cars is the man
right there see like a dr. Cox he is cut
through [ __ ] traffic were like Suns
Aniki a [ __ ] bicycle
mad flavor here talking to my little
brother's here dropping knowledge on on
his [ __ ] they want about my little
freaks what do you want over the top
they want a little fight stop that balls
look like Vicky what are you gonna do
these are my little G's right here later
she said
just cut away through traffic with my
boy here what [ __ ] ratio of life with
all these suckers driving through
traffic I'm over you look like a doctor
what's happening sexy
who's this guy here who's this dolly
eyes I love it with my buddies
running with the kids you little
Anderson Silva
all right stay black cravings it's all
you got at the end of the day
Justin people
get down [ __ ] Volvo Joey stay black
[ __ ]
he was back slingin thick and giving out
bubble baby for look at you likes to
laugh those little glasses huh
I don't forget about I'm trying to get
these guys hooked up with some freaks
tonight wait thank guys you guys Mike
Sharpe is a little freak right here with
you think little [ __ ] Valenza so what
do you think guys should I fix these
little guys up with some freaks who are
you do I get some big fat [ __ ]
titties what do you think okay stay
black
walk it up a little dancing
I play the world
oh all right well here look at this [ __ ]
we're just leaving the fights my man
here he's a white dude ain't even
Japanese stay black [ __ ]
they don't